méfiez-vous Thierry quand même c'est
quand même lui qui vous a remplacé sur
France 2 vous avez peur ah non moi j'ai
pas peur mais si ça se trouve il est pas
invité il est en repérage
[Applaudissements]
les tweets de la semaine passée
n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à commenter en
direct sur Twitter hashtag slt on les
lira hashtag hashtag salut et terrien
c'est important de le dire vous êtes pas
sur Twitter qu'est-ce que vous en savez
Thierry
bon en tout cas la semaine dernière on
se fait Lindsey Stirling grande
violoniste internationale voilà comme on
peut le voir qui est un petit peu la
fille caché de Mylène Farmer et d'André
Rieu et il se trouve que l'INSEE est
mormone voilà ça fait beaucoup réagir
comme ce tweet de David qui nous dit une
violoniste mormone il y a cardison pour
nous montrer ça
c'est bien c'est l'ouverture voilà la
semaine prochaine on recevra un pianiste
chiite et
le mois prochain un guitariste auraélien
donc c'est très important et puis sur
Twitter aussi Thierry on a découvert que
vous aviez des de nombreux fans comme
Stéphanie voilà qui nous dit je suis
tellement fan de Thierry Ardisson mon
rêve c'est de travailler avec lui je
suis même à laver ses slips je m'en fous
et bah Stéphanie hop
tu as du boulot voilà je t'envoie tout
ça par courtier
et toi
[Rires]
Gainsbourg disait je ne porte pas de
slip ça fait pansement je trouve qu'il
avait assez raison bah désolé Stéphanie
du coup pas de boulot
un dernier tweet Thierry on s'est moqué
de vous la semaine dernière
comme nous le dit Émilie Marie victoire
qui nous dit c'est moi ou la maquilleuse
au Salut les Terriens a eu la main
lourde sur la Terracotta non c'est que
je reviens de vacances c'est tout comme
d'habitude non mais les gens sont
méchants à cause d'un tweet il y a
peut-être quelqu'un qui va perdre son
boulot quand même c'est ça en plus non
c'est pas vrai en plus est-ce qu'on peut
voir des images de Thierry au maquillage
la semaine dernière
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes chanteuse danseuse chorégraphe
écrivain comédienne et surtout
définissez comme une décomplexée du cul
et ben bienvenue chez Thierry Ardisson
bienvenue chez vous
viens on peut dire vous avez été SM et
vous avez fréquenté les clubs
échangistes comme pas mal de célébrités
et non et aujourd'hui c'est fini vous
êtes avec le Mario au guitariste de
votre groupe voilà on dirait un peu la
vie de Catherine Ringer et oui venez
nous voir pour votre livre comme l'a dit
Thierry Holly citoyen le manifeste
contre la société de la malbaise tout le
monde se focalise sur la malbouffe mais
vous c'est la malbaisse vous êtes un peu
la Jean-Pierre Coffe du cul
non mais vous avez raison parce que la
malbaisse un problème beaucoup plus
sérieux que la malbouffe ce qui a un mec
qui bouffe mal au pire et rentre plus
dans son jean voilà alors que un mec qui
baise mal bah il devient aigri il aime
plus son prochain il commence à lire les
étrangers et il finit par devenir
chroniqueur dans NPC au côté d'Eric
Naulleau
alors vous avez dit pour vous la nudité
Julia c'est un moyen de célébrer les
corps et les différences et je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous c'est la
nudité est un moyen de célébrer les
corps et les différences en tout cas
c'est ce que me répétait tous les
mercredis le Père Jean au catéchisme
en tout cas
c'est un super plateau ce soir Laurent
Ruquier et Jean-Jacques Bourdin réunis
les deux parlent très fort à la radio
Bourdin parce qu'il est énervé et
Laurent parce que ces auditeurs sont
sourds
ok bonsoir soir méfiez-vous Thierry
quand même c'est quand même lui qui vous
a remplacé sur France 2 vous avez peur
ah non moi j'ai pas peur mais si ça se
trouve il est pas invité il est en
repérage
pour les musées
à chaque fois que vous êtes invité
quelque part les gens vendent votre côté
couteau suisse c'est vrai ou les fêtes
Thierry animateur radio téléproducteurs
auteurs patrons de théâtre faut qu'on
arrête d'Emmer des ruquiers c'est quand
même le dernier homme de gauche qui
bosse et qui ramène des résultats c'est
quand même
bon ok vous êtes à la tête des grosses
têtes pour la troisième saison sur RTL
ça tient un petit peu justement en froid
avec Philippe Bouvard mais c'est du
passé parce que j'ai vu qu'à la
conférence de presse cette année vous
êtes réconcilié avec lui comme quoi
Alzheimer ça a pas que des mauvais côtés
en tout cas vous êtes ce soir ici invité
et c'est le dramaturge qu'on reçoit avec
votre nouvelle pièce qui s'appelle à
gauche à droite à droite à gauche c'est
sur les opinions politiques c'est pas
votre façon de porter à droite ou à
gauche
en tout cas vous avez réuni au théâtre
Francis Huster et Régis Laspalès
c'est horrible pourquoi c'est séparer
chevalier à Laspalès qui va faire la pub
pour la Matmut maintenant on sait pas
notre dernière invité c'est le troisième
Jean-Jacques le plus célèbre de France
après Rousseau et Goldman
on s'emballe pas
pourtant ce n'est ni une lumière ni un
Jean-Jacques Bourdin bonsoir
vous présentez la matinale des MC tous
les matins de 6 heures à 10h ça
s'appelle Bourdin direct c'est vrai que
sur RMC l'avantage c'est qu'on s'emmerde
pas avec les titres on va l'efficace la
matinale c'est qui Bourdin ok il est en
direct Bourdin direct après il y a quoi
deux mecs qui gueule et les Grandes
Gueules voilà on se regarde pas dans
votre matinale le climax c'est aux
interview d'homme politique enfin
souvent on sait pas si c'est une
interview ou une garde à vue mais c'est
le c'est la seule quand même émission de
télé où les politiques sont en cellules
psychologique après l'émission
bon par contre vous refusez toujours de
déjeuner ou dîner avec les hommes
politiques toujours c'est con quand même
mais pourquoi ça passe en note de frais
c'est l'État qui paye c'est pas vous bon
et Jean-Jacques j'ai découvert que vous
êtes protestants même dans la religion
il est contre tout le monde
bon pour terminer mesdames et pour vous
poser les questions trop con que Thierry
Ardisson n'a toujours pas voulu vous
poser
Julia palombe Julien vous êtes pour
qu'on libère tous les corps même celui
de Christine Boutin tous sans exception
Jean-Jacques Bourdin est-ce que c'est
vrai qu'on vous engueulez avec votre
femme et vous dit ah ça va tu es pas au
boulot
Jean-Jacques Bourdin vous prenez jamais
de beurre mais toujours des taxis c'est
pour être plus près de vos auditeurs et
qui vous dit que je prends des excès
alors ok c'est vrai que vous prenez
jamais de beurre mais toujours des taxis
pour être plus près de vos auditeurs
aussi je prends les deux pour tout vous
dire franchement comme ça ça fait encore
plus de monde et pour terminer Laurent
Ruquier quand vous étiez enfant au trêve
de gosse c'était de présenter les
Grosses Têtes de RTL quand vous serez
vieux vous devez faire quoi le 6/9
d'énergie du coup
non il y a déjà des lieux aussi Snoop
d'énergie bon Dieu bonne émission salut
voilà c'est guilton villa et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu